hey youtubers it's Charlie so this is
going to be my Harley Quinn Joker video
for Suicide Squad we haven't really
talked about her in a while this film is
going to be something of an origin story
for her character and they'll change a
few things from the comics but even if
you've been reading her for a long time
in the comics if you watch the animated
series it's all going to be in there you
may have heard stories about how they're
tinkering with Batman V Superman to make
it more of a Batman story than it is a
Superman story because they're so
excited about Ben Affleck's Batman but I
think the deal with the Suicide Squad
movie is that they always intended to do
something like that with the Joker and
Harley Quinn's character Harlequin
getting the origin story when we see
Suicide Squad Joker will already be
Joker that's what I think some of these
images from the trailer are all about
him dipping her in the vat of chemicals
if you remember some of the Batman V
Superman trailers we actually see ace
chemicals so I'm wondering if that is
where this is happening in the Suicide
Squad trailer remember this is a shared
universe so just expect some of the
locations that you see in Gotham in
Batman V Superman to show up during
Suicide Squad but even though they'll be
telling this joker harley quinn story
within Suicide Squad it's still the
story of how the Suicide Squad becomes
the Suicide Squad or Task Force X
however you want to think about it
originally it started as Task Force X
but most people just call it suicide
squad harley quinn no WTF is harley
quinn most of you probably know her from
the animated series that's where she
debuted bruce timm is her creator she's
one of the very few comic book
characters that was created during the
1990s that became super popular the most
popular comic book characters you see
nowadays Batman Superman The Avengers
all those characters were created 30 40
50 years ago there are very few super
popular characters that were created in
more recent years harley quinn and
deadpool are my favorite examples now
they're very different characters but
they're popular for relatively the same
reason they're more adult spin on
characters that were originally written
for children that came during an era of
comics when the biggest heroes were
really adult like Wolverine was one of
the most popular comic book characters
in the 90s and he was super adult super
hardcore compared to the rest of the
Marvel Universe DC characters is the
same thing on DC side so during the 90s
you see all the big titles start to go
away dark x-men goes dark Batman gets
dark art they break his back they
introduced the bane character they
entered
his doomsday they kill Superman the 90s
was a period when relatively silly comic
book characters grew up a little bit so
Harley Quinn was kind of an amalgam of a
lot of those things she was a more adult
take on a character that kids loved but
because it was in the animated series it
was a character that was really easy to
expose to kids but that adults would
also enjoy so she had this broad
spectrum appeal where she was one hot
too she was funny and three she got to
hang out with one of the coolest comic
book villains the Joker now one of the
few minor differences to her origin
story that they might use in the movie
is where she shows up because the Joker
is in prison she's a psychiatrist he
being the Joker very charismatic twists
her and she falls in love with him and
takes the Harley Quinn persona breaks
them out and they go on their crime
spree have all kinds of crazy adventures
together it's a lot of fun all in the
animated series I would actually
recommend that you watch that before you
read her in the comic books they've
changed her quite a bit in the new 52
they've done a lot of different things
with the character one of the more
recent changes which you might find
blasphemous if you're big Harley Quinn
fan is a dress for a relationship with
the Joker in a more literal way take it
more seriously like why is this woman
hanging out with this abusive man so
recently Harley Quinn's kind of told The
Joker off just because I think they
wanted a more positive spin on what was
going on with her character like if she
were to really come to her senses and
realize the Joker's a terrible person
why would she continued to stay with
them if you want the classic harley
quinn persona where the dream is still
alive where the Joker and her still have
this awesome relationship just avoid the
new 52 in the comics she was a
psychiatrist at Arkham I don't know
they're gonna change that for the movie
or not it might be Blackgate prison
there are a number of big prisons in the
DC Universe were they house
supervillains so we'll see I know when
we meet her in the movie for the first
time she's already Harley Quinn she's
going to be working with the Suicide
Squad so they'll probably deal with her
backstory in the way Deadpool dealt with
Deadpool's backstory like how they flash
back briefly and then fast forward to
present day like you're introduced to
her for the first time in all her Harley
Quinn gory she's just being this amazing
character and then they break up a bunch
of different flashbacks through the
movie to explain how she got to that
point and the other thing too we don't
really know is how they're going to
treat her relationship with Joker in
modern day because there are a couple
different things going on in Suicide
Squad one they'll have a mission
vert some giant crisis like oh my god
this is so dangerous that we don't want
to send our own people and so will send
in the comic book Expendables enter Task
Force X then you'll also have these
other antagonists like the Joker like it
seems like they're going after the
tattooed man like he's going to be one
of the villains of the movie there's
still a lot of uncertainty because I
feel like any story The Joker shows up
in he's automatically going to be the
coolest villain even if he's not the
main antagonist of the film so don't be
surprised if there's a point during the
film where Harley Quinn tells The Joker
off or seemingly swap sides back and
forth because that's kind of her think
she's always going to be obsessed with
the Joker whether she likes him or not
there have been certain periods in the
comics when she's been left to rot in
jail by the Joker and then there are
other times when he uses opportunities
to break her out usually only when it
serves his purpose like if he has some
big mission and she just happens to be
around like oh ok I'll break you out too
so you get the idea the Joker is an
equal opportunity dirtbag even to the
people who seemingly care about him but
that's really the fun part of the
Harlequin character exploring what it is
that makes her like the Joker so much I
mean this is still a big comic book
movie don't expect it to go all
christopher nolan and get super cerebral
like interstellar or something like that
it's still going to be a lot of fun but
I feel like if you've been a big fan of
Harley Quinn's character for a long time
you always come back around to two big
things one that wisecracking
unpredictable nature like Deadpool she's
kind of a Deadpool type character into
what's going on inside her head why is
she so batshit crazy for the Joker and
as crazy as she it is part of the fun of
the character is watching her turn on a
dime and go from really silly to really
angry but if you really like the
Deadpool movie which most of you
probably did a lot of that energy is
going to be in the Suicide Squad movie
now Suicide Squad is going to be pg-13
but I feel like the only difference
between Deadpool's are and suicide
squads pg-13 is a little less TNA so let
me know in the comments what's your
favorite thing about the Harley Quinn
character is it her relationship with
the Joker is it just watching her bounce
forth between really silly and really
crazy all the time and would you want to
see a Harley Quinn spin-off movie if the
Suicide Squad is as successful as they
want it to be I feel like they're gonna
try and spin out a Harley Quinn
franchise I'd rather see that than some
of the other Suicide Squad characters
get their own movie everybody's been
talking about getting a female-led
superhero film like Marvel doing captain
marvel we have Wonder Woman coming I
feel like DC could also double down and
if Margot Robbie's performance is
compelling enough I mean we haven't seen
the movie yet they could do a Harley
Quinn movie that just feels like
something that would be awesome they no
mistake though unless the movie
completely tanks which I don't think it
will there will be a Suicide Squad too
it's just not on the books yet they're
not going to green lighted until they
release the first movie in slightly
related news apparently Anthony Mackie
was talking about Hulk things going on
in captain america civil war I'll
probably do a video about that next so
be sure to subscribe to get that if
there are any suicide squad or Batman V
Superman movie videos that you guys want
me to do just let me know in the
comments we're basically a month away
from daredevil season 2 dropping the
Punisher looks amazing in Batman V
Superman coming out that's how close it
is it's right around the corner white
goes wait for me to finish that video
you can click here to learn all about
the Deadpool sequel dead pulling cable
and you can click here for all my
Suicide Squad videos thank you so much
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight